Claudia: From calorie
count to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out all the differences
between Five Guys in Italy and the US.
This is "Food Wars."
Burgers in Italy come in two
sizes, little and regular.
Little has one patty, and regular has two.
Our burgers also come in two
sizes, little and regular.
Let's weigh a regular plain
hamburger in both countries
to see who has the bigger burgers.
That's 136 grams.
Nico: 138 grams.
The burger mark is really off-putting.
Any difference might
be down to the patties.
Five Guys actually tells
us that the US patties
should weigh about 94
grams each, or 3.3 ounces,
although this will be the
weight before cooking.
The Five Guys Italy website says
that the patties when uncooked
should weigh 67 grams,
so we're going to see if that's true.
Obviously this has been cooked,
so the meat should have released some fat,
but we're going to find out soon.
This is a Five Guys hot dog.
It looks a little weird
because they slice them down
the middle to cook them.
I really love how these
cook when they're sliced.
Let's measure the length first.
That's about 16.2 centimeters.
I think that's about 15 centimeters.
Yeah, 6 inches.
We don't use inches in Italy.
Now let's weigh the plain hot dog.
That is 144 grams.
We're now going to weigh it.
So, just for reference,
we put mustard, ketchup,
and onions in this hot dog,
so obviously it's going
to be a bit heavier
than the regular one. Let's see.
195 grams.
Our fries come in three sizes
in either plain or Cajun spice.
You can get little, regular, or large.
Our Five Guys fries come in three sizes,
either plain or with Cajun spice.
Little, regular, and large.
According to Five Guys, the
little should weigh 227 grams.
Let's see if that's true.
It's not. It's 82 grams.
This is 82, oh, wait,
yeah, it's 82 grams.
Our little fries should weigh 256 grams.
103 grams.
So, we did ask a Five Guys employee
about how they package their fries.
They scoop the fries
into one of these cups,
put that in the bag, and
then they do another scoop
of fries on top, I think.
So that could be the reason why
some of these weights are off.
There's just, like, fries everywhere.
Don't really know which
fry came from which cup.
It's a mess.
We're supposed to have
1,225 grams altogether,
but right now we're sitting at 870 grams,
including the "extra fries,"
which aren't really extra.
So, our total should
have been 1,220 grams,
but we got 580 grams.
So that's less than half.
Milkshakes in Italy come in one size,
and this is supposed
to be 400 milliliters.
So, this is the vanilla milkshake.
In the US, I believe we only
have one size of milkshake.
So let's see how much we get.
It's actually almost 500.
I'll say it's, like,
480 millimeters.
Something around that.
Here's everything you'll
find at Five Guys in the US
that you won't find in Italy.
Here's everything you'll
find at Five Guys Italy
that you won't find in the US.
The owners of Five Guys like to keep
the restaurants and
the menus all the same,
so there aren't any exclusive
burger options in the US.
This is the Five Guys burger menu.
So, our burger menus are
almost exactly the same.
The only difference is that here
you can order two additional
patties, not just one.
So you end up with a burger
with four patties in it.
I'm not sure you can do that in the US.
Maybe if you ask nicely.
But it's an official feature here.
Since Five Guys is known for
its customizable options,
you probably could order two
extra patties for your burger,
but we'll let you have this one, Claudia.
But seeing as America doesn't have
official exclusive menu items,
Five Guys enthusiasts had to get creative
and make their own in the form
of an unofficial secret menu.
So, this is the patty melt.
It's a grilled cheese sandwich
with an extra patty inside.
It looks kind of good to me.
I love when restaurants do grilled cheeses
with the buns of the burgers.
I think it tastes so good.
I feel like I like this better
than the Five Guys burgers.
It's something about the way
the bread gets all toasty.
It just makes it so much more delicious!
So, next is the artery annihilator.
That's a little ridiculous.
So, we have to put a bacon hot dog
inside of a bacon cheeseburger.
How I'm going to do that, I don't know.
What I think is right is
making it edible in some form,
so I'm just going to break it up a little.
I'm trying to squish it
down because it's not
going to fit into my mouth. OK.
This literally sucks.
Like, don't order this.
There's no reason for you to --
if you want a hot dog and a burger ...
let me swallow this stupid bite of food.
Hold on.
I feel like putting the
hot dog into the burger
doesn't make it taste any better.
It just makes it a lot harder to eat
and a lot less enjoyable of an experience,
so I think this is really not fun or good.
To me, I think this should be at the top.
So let's try.
Double bread?
Yeah, there's a bit of sauce.
All right.
So, here's your Italian version.
Artery annihilator, right?
I don't know. I feel like this is
annihilating my eyesight as well
on top of my arteries if I were to try it.
Too much stuff.
Five Guys is of course famous
for its wide selection of free toppings.
According to Five Guys,
there are over 250,000 ways
to customize your burger.
Now, these aren't exclusive toppings,
but here's what you can get.
The only exclusive
topping we have in America
is A.1. sauce.
In Italy, the toppings are
almost exactly the same
as in the US, but we do
have one exclusive sauce,
which is the HP sauce.
According to chefs at Five Guys,
when customizing your burger,
there's a specific way
it has to be stacked
within their rules.
It should be the bottom bun;
then any wet items, like
grilled onions or mushrooms;
then the first patty;
two slices of cheese;
then another patty;
then dry items like lettuce, tomatoes,
and jalapeños go on top;
and then there's the top
bun to finish it all off.
Let's see if it came in the order
that it's supposed to come in.
So, at the bottom I
see the grilled onions,
I see grilled mushrooms,
and I also see peppers, green peppers.
So it's already out of order
because the jalapeños are on
the bottom for some reason.
I feel like, I don't
know, I feel like this,
if it doesn't affect the taste,
I personally do not care.
But if it's their law in the Five Guys,
then I guess you should
be doing it. I don't know.
All right, so we got the first patty,
the two slices of cheese, another patty,
and then on top we have
the lettuce and tomatoes.
Let's check if the order
is the same here in Italy.
So, yes, we got bottom
bun, onions and mushrooms.
We got a patty, cheese,
we got another patty,
tomatoes, and lettuce at the top.
Good job, Five Guys.
Five Guys also offers sandwich options.
There aren't any exclusive
sandwiches in the US,
but here's what you can get.
So, we have a grilled cheese,
a BLT, and a veggie sandwich.
Veggie sandwich.
Mm-mm.
It's not bad,
it's just a little too
vegetable-heavy for me.
No.
Next is the BLT, which,
if you mess this up ...
Yeah, it tastes like an OK BLT.
It just mostly tastes like bacon.
And then we have the grilled cheese,
which I think will be good
because I already liked the patty melt,
and they're like sisters.
That's a really good grilled cheese.
We do have one exclusive in Italy,
which is a BLT sandwich with cheese,
which is supposed to be this one,
but there's been a bit
of a mix-up in the order,
and the one we got has just
cheese and a lot of bacon.
There aren't any exclusive
Five Guys hot-dog options
in either country, but
here's what you can get.
A hot dog, a bacon dog,
a cheese dog, or a bacon cheese dog.
I've never had a hot
dog with cheese on it,
so I am kind of intrigued.
I will say, though, I am a
fan of the slicing the hot dog
and putting this side on the griddle,
just so everything gets nice and crispy.
I think they do taste better that way.
It's not for me.
Something about the cheese
and the hot dog mixing
together feels wrong,
because I've never had it. It feels weird.
So, this is the bacon and cheese hot dog.
Looks pretty good to me,
but I'm not really familiar with hot dogs.
I think in general in Italy we
don't really have that many.
Definitely burgers are more popular.
Yeah, maybe with some sauce
it would be a bit better.
In the US, we have two
exclusive milkshake options,
the Oreo creme and the Double Stuf,
which I am very excited about.
I love Oreos, and Oreo milkshakes
are objectively the best milkshake.
Let's try the Oreo creme first.
So, this is just the filling
of the Oreos, essentially.
OK, give it a good swirl.
And it is creme and not cream.
That is literally so good.
You're actually drinking
the creme inside of an Oreo.
Next is Double Stuf.
So I assume this has the creme
and also a bunch of Oreo pieces in it.
Oh, my God, this is the best one.
At Five Guys, you can actually add bacon
to any of their milkshake flavors.
This is a vanilla bacon.
I just feel like vanilla seemed like
the easiest thing to pair with the bacon.
I've never tried this
before, but let's see.
It tastes like vanilla and bacon.
I'm just trying to decide mentally
if that's, like, something
I should have eaten.
We thought we had one exclusive
in the milkshake department in Italy.
On their website, it still states
that there is a coffee
milkshake that you can order.
We did order it, but then
when we got to the store
to collect it, turns out
it's been discontinued.
And it's been years they haven't done it.
So please update your website, Five Guys.
We still got a bacon milkshake,
and then weirdly on the website also,
it lets you add every single flavor,
so we got a milkshake
with absolutely everything
that was available.
What's in here? There is
Oreos, bananas, strawberry.
There's so many different
things that just,
in my mind, they don't
really work together.
I think there's just too many things
to even make out what stuff is.
To be honest, it's not too bad.
Now we've got the bacon milkshake.
Mixed in bacon with milk.
It does sound a bit ridiculous.
I'm a bit disappointed, though,
because I don't really
taste the bacon much.
We also have some drink options
you can only get in the US,
Simply lemonade, root beer, and Dr Pepper.
Do Italians like root beer?
That's what I would love to know.
You know what that is. I'm sure they do.
If you're Italian, from
Italy, comment down below
and tell me if you know
what root beer is, one,
and two, do you actually think it's good?
Because here, people love it.
And here are all the drinks
that you can only find in Italy.
We've got Fanta orange, sparkling water,
and then four beers.
So, let's talk about prices now.
In Italy at Five Guys, a cheeseburger
will cost you 13 euros and 45 cents.
Translated to dollars, that is $14.82.
So, for comparison, at
McDonald's you can get
a cheeseburger for 2 euros.
So yeah, for the same price,
13-point-something euros,
you could get six of
these at the other chain.
That's maybe too cheap,
but 13 euros for a burger in tinfoil
just sort of all squished together
still at a fast-food chain,
that's way, way over what I would pay.
In the US, a cheeseburger
will cost you $11.79,
or 10 euros and 70 cents.
That is a 26% decrease in price.
So, Five Guys is doing this thing
where all of their food is
fresh and made to order.
They're trying to kind
of raise the standard
of what fast food could be.
I think that's why their
prices are on the higher end,
although I don't know if
that's fully justified,
because I can say
that I've had better, cheaper burgers.
I think that's allowed.
And to make that a meal,
so with a regular fries and a drink,
that will cost you 23 euros and 20 cents,
which in dollars is $25.57.
Again, so overpriced.
Like, 23 euros for all this,
and I still don't even have a plate.
It's just a lot. A lot.
To make it a meal with regular
fries and a regular drink,
it will cost you $21.47,
or 19 euros and 48 cents.
I ... it's just not making sense to me.
$21 for a fast-food
burger, fries, and drink,
no. Absolutely not.
Let's take a look at some
of the basic ingredients
at a Five Guys Italy.
In Italy, the burger itself,
it's 100% ground beef.
And in the US, a burger actually contains
80/20 USDA ground chuck.
If you want to add cheese
to your burger, though,
here's everything that's in the cheese.
Five Guys cheese in the US contains
all of these ingredients.
Let's look at the bun.
It contains water, salt,
sugar, vegetable shortening,
milk, eggs, bleached bread flour,
yeast, and sesame seeds.
So, in Italy the bun has
a total of 11 ingredients.
That's two more than the US.
The additional ingredients
are calcium carbonate
and spirit vinegar.
The only difference in the hot dogs
is some of the ingredients
to make the pink coloring.
We love dyeing our food here.
The ingredients for the
fries are really simple.
It's just potatoes, refined
peanut oil, and salt.
If you go to a Five Guys,
they have this little board
that tells you where your
potatoes are coming from that day,
and ours came from St. Anthony, Idaho.
And the fries at Five
Guys are very simple.
They are potatoes, peanut oil, and salt.
It's the first thing that
I see something cooked
with peanut oil.
Let's see. Do they taste
like peanuts at all, or?
Actually, they taste quite potatoey.
Like, they taste quite nice.
Yeah, maybe it's the peanut oil after all.
In the US, a cheeseburger
that has a bun, two patties,
two pieces of cheese, and no toppings
comes out to about 984 calories.
The total fat comes out to about 55 grams,
carbs 39 grams,
sugar 8 grams,
and sodium 1,050 milligrams.
In Italy, a regular cheeseburger contains
756 calories,
of which 45 grams are total fat,
40 grams are carbs,
8 grams are sugar,
and 908 milligrams are sodium.
And if you make that a
meal, you can add fries,
and they contain 1,122 calories,
then 66 grams of fat,
120 grams of carbs,
1.7 grams of sugar,
and 716 milligrams of sodium.
Our regular fries are 953 calories,
41 grams of fat,
131 grams of carbs,
4 grams of sugar,
and 962 milligrams of sodium.
And a chocolate milkshake contains
874 calories,
then 39 grams of fat,
121 grams of carbs,
108 grams of sugar,
and 408 milligrams of sodium.
And a chocolate milkshake is 830 calories,
36 grams of fat,
116 grams of carbs,
107 grams of sugar,
and 400 milligrams of sodium.
So, the total for a meal
that includes a cheeseburger,
regular fries, and the milkshake
is 2,752 calories,
of which 150 grams are total fat,
then 281 grams carbs,
118 grams of sugar,
and 2,032 milligrams of sodium.
Bringing the total to 2,767 calories,
132 grams of total fat,
286 grams of carbs,
119 grams of sugar,
and 2,412 milligrams of sodium.
Well, the numbers for the
fries are actually based on
what is stated on the website,
and we got basically half
of what is stated there.
So if you want to make this
a little bit more accurate,
you should halve the
nutrition numbers as well.
Five Guys first opened
in Italy in 2018 in Milan
just behind the Duomo, so
a very touristic location.
And then in 2021 after
a bit of a COVID break,
it opened in Rome, and there are now
another four locations in Milan.
I think, well, starting with Milan,
it's a very smart choice.
Obviously it's the most
international city.
There's a lot of tourists,
like, fashion capital of Italy,
a lot of offices, a lot of
foreigners as well here,
which is maybe the reason
why they opened here.
I know Five Guys is
available in a lot of places,
but something about the branding
and the way the food is presented
feels very East Coast to me.
I think it's because the fries
remind me of boardwalk fries
that you'd get down at the Jersey shore.
It's a little weird because some stuff
has the Five Guys logo on it
and you can tell where it's from.
Other stuff, like the
fries and the burgers,
just come in regular foil,
a regular unmarked cup.
So it's like, it's not a
lot of brand recognition,
at least for me.
I've never even seen a
Five Guys advertisement.
I've never seen a commercial.
I've never gotten an ad.
Once you take this cup away,
you probably wouldn't know
where I got this food from.
Because their burgers are made to order,
it does take longer for
you to get your order.
I've waited, like, at least 10 minutes
for my order at a Five Guys before,
so it's not the fastest fast-food option.
But the food is as fresh as it can be.
It kind of gives me the feeling
of food you'd get at a concession stand
at a local baseball game
at a school or something.
It's definitely got
its own thing going on.